David Boder: [In English] Munich, September the 24th, 1946, at the UNRRA University of the Deutsches Museum. The interviewee is Mr. Victor Ferdinansk, a Lithuanian, who will talk to us in German.
David Boder: [In German] Also sagen Sie mir, Victor, was ist Ihnen passiert, wenn die Russen nach Litauen gekommen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Also die Russen sind nach Litauen gekommen 1940. Damals war ich im Gymnasium in der dritten Klasse und im Herbst dieses Jahres bin ich gekommen nach Tallin in die achte Lasse des Ritter Seminars.
David Boder: Von welcher Religion sind Sie?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ich bin römisch katholisch.
David Boder: Ja. Weiter nun.
Victor Ferdinansk: Und es war uns allen klar, dass das Ritter Seminar nicht lange bestehen wird.
David Boder: In welcher Stadt was das Seminar?
Victor Ferdinansk: In Tallin...Kovno.
David Boder: In Kovno? Das hat man damals genannt das Kovno Theologisches Seminar?
Victor Ferdinansk: Kovno Theologisches Seminar.
David Boder: Bei Riga? Nun...
Victor Ferdinansk: Als Angehöriger des Franziskaner Ordens wurde ich von mein...von unserem Vorgesetzten nach Deutschland geschickt mit dem Auftrag nach Italien zu kommen. Damals studierten nämlich in Italien viele unserer Landsleute und sie hatten diese Dokumente schon für uns besorgt.
David Boder: Also was heißt diese Dokumente? Was für Dokumente haben Sie gebraucht?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das heißt Einreise-Dokumente nach Italien.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Aber wir waren sehr tief enttäuscht, als wir uns nach Deutschland begeben haben.
Victor Ferdinansk: Ich habe die Absicht gehabt nach Italien zu kommen, aber an Stelle dessen ist etwas Anderes eingetroffen. Ich wurde beim illegalen Überschreiten der Grenze...
David Boder: Oh, sie haben die Grenze illegal überschritten?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja. Ich wurde fest genommen und in ein Lager gebracht, wo ich sieben Tage gehalten wurde. Aber dann wurde gesehen, dass ich kein Spion bin. Dann wurde ich mit einem (unverständlich) nach Berlin geschickt, wo ich mit französischen Gefangenen im Deutschen Verlag als Gefangener Dienste leisten musste.
David Boder: Also Sie haben nicht einen Pass-Schein nach Italien?
Victor Ferdinansk: Nein.
David Boder: Sie haben Sie als Gefangenen genommen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, ich wurde verhaftet und zur Arbeit gebracht.
David Boder: Bitte weiter.
Victor Ferdinansk: Und nachdem ich ungefähr drei oder Monate gearbeitet habe...
David Boder: Haben Sie einem Lager gelabt?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das war ein Arbeiterlager.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: In diesem Zimmer haben geschlafen sehr viele. Ich glaube so viel wie fünfzig Leute zumindest.
David Boder: Ja, nun und...
Victor Ferdinansk: Und ja einmal wurde das ganze Haus, wo jeder - alle zusammen gewohnt haben, untersucht und auf Grund meiner Nationalität wurde ich von der Gestapo andermal festgenommen und in Berlin auf das Polizei Präsidium gebracht. Die haben mich drei Stunden lang untersucht, gefragt nach verschiedenen Sachen, also dann stellte sich heraus, dass ich kein gefährlicher Mensch bin, sondern bloß Student der Theologie.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Und ich wurde nach der drei stündigen Untersuchung entlassen.
David Boder: Nun.
Victor Ferdinansk: Diese ganze Geschichte war mir sehr unangenehm und ich wollte nicht, dass es irgendwelchen Folgen hat. Darum bin ich auch von Berlin nach München gekommen.
David Boder: Also wieso...ille...
Victor Ferdinansk: Illegal.
David Boder: Illegal. Nun sagen Sie mir, haben Sie sich nicht mit den katholischen Geistlichen verständigen können, dass man Ihnen hilft? Mit den Franziskanern?
Victor Ferdinansk: Nein, in Berlin, das war fast nicht möglich, weil jede Behörde war sehr eingestellt gegen die Religion und es war wirklich nichts zu machen.
David Boder: Nun?
Victor Ferdinansk: Und damals war ich sehr jung und habe sehr schlecht die deutsche Sprache beherrscht.
David Boder: Hat man Ihnen erlaubt zur Kirche zu gehen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das Kirchen Gehen hat man erlaubt zu gehen.
David Boder: Konnten Sie da nicht mit dem Vater sprechen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Praktisch konnten die nicht viel helfen. Denn um Einen in der Pfarre aufzunehmen, sollten die auch eine polizeiliche Genehmigung haben. Und ohne diese polizeiliche Genehmigung durften sie überhaupt niemanden aufnehmen. Darum habe ich beschlossen nach Bayern zu flüchten, wo das ganze Land katholisch ist.
David Boder: Nun?
Victor Ferdinansk: Und...
David Boder: Sie kamen dann nach München?
Victor Ferdinansk: Nach München. 1941 bin ich nach München gekommen, wo ich in einem Franziskanischen Kloster aufgenommen wurde und bis zum Jahre neunzehn hundert fünf und vierzig (1945) beschäftigt wurde als Litauer und Ausländer.
David Boder: Aha. Also da haben die Deutschen nachher doch gewusst, dass Sie dort waren?
Victor Ferdinansk: Später...das haben sie nicht gewusst. Aber später selbstverständlich als ich angemeldet wurde, wurde das, hm,...
David Boder: [unverständlich]
Victor Ferdinansk: Ein Gestapo Beamter ist gekommen. Die ganze Sache hat sich herausgestellt und er hatte dann folgende Anordnung gegeben: Ich darf nicht in zivil...in die Stadt hinaus gehen nicht in Zivilkleider, wie das heißt, nur in Ordern...
David Boder: Nun?
Victor Ferdinansk: . . . bis damals war erlaubt, dass man auch in Zivilkleidern in die Stadt hinaus gehen zu können.
David Boder: Hm.
Victor Ferdinansk: Dann zweitens war mir der Auftrag erlegt, dass ich jede Woche mich beim zuständigen Polizei Präsidium oder Revier melden muss.
David Boder: Nun.
Victor Ferdinansk: Es war mir verboten litauisch auf der Strasse zu sprechen
David Boder: Oh ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Und es war mir verboten an andere litauische Briefe zu schreiben, in litauischer Sprach.
David Boder: Hm, aber Sie konnten doch in deutsch schreiben?
Victor Ferdinansk: In deutscher Sprache durfte ich nicht schreiben.
David Boder: Zu wem haben Sie dann schreiben können oder wollen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Gewöhnlich habe ich einen anderen Briefverkehr unterhalten mit meinen Freunden, mit andere Leut...
David Boder: Wo? Hier in Deutschland?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja.
David Boder: Aha, nun weiter. Durch dieser ganzen Zeit haben die Deutschen Sie jemals geschlagen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Da ich ein Theologie Student gewesen bin, selbstverständlich bin ich nicht zu Schlägereien gekommen.
David Boder: Warum ist das selbstverständlich? Sie haben mir gesagt, dass die Deutschen die Religion nicht sehr respektiert haben.
Victor Ferdinansk: Das stimmt schon.
David Boder: Aber soweit sie betroffen waren...?
Victor Ferdinansk: Aber in dem Kloster...im Kloster habe ich eine katholische Umgebung gehabt und es ist nicht dazu gekommen.
David Boder: Was haben Sie im Kloster getan?
Victor Ferdinansk: Im Kloster? Das ist sehr schwer zu sagen. Wir waren...
David Boder: Wurden Sie behandelt wie alle Anderen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das kann man nicht sagen, ich habe immer gespürt, dass ich ein Ausländer bin. Und die haben immer uns zu verstehen gegeben, dass wir Ausländer sind und wir waren jeder, hm, in jeder...
David Boder: Beziehung.
Victor Ferdinansk: . . . in jeder Beziehung ignoriert, darum...
David Boder: Bei den anderen Leuten oder den Franziskanern?
Victor Ferdinansk: Auch.
David Boder: Von den Brüdern?
Victor Ferdinansk: Auch von den Brüdern.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Und darum habe ich beschlossen in 1900...im Jahre 1945 als die Amerikaner gekommen sind und die Zivil...die Zivillager eingerichtet haben, aus dem Kloster einzutreten...
David Boder: Auszutreten.
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, auszutreten und das habe ich gemacht.
David Boder: Hm. Nun was studieren Sie jetzt hier?
Victor Ferdinansk: Jetzt an dieser Universität studiere ich Jura und bin im zweiten Semester.
David Boder: Also Sie haben die Theologie aufgegeben?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ich habe die Theologie aufgegeben und nur aus diesem Grunde, dass ich nicht in Deutschland bleiben wollte und als Geistlicher unter Deutschen arbeiten.
David Boder: Sagen Sie mir...es ist...sehr interessant, dass ich Sie getroffen habe. Was haben die Franziskaner Brüder von den Nazis gedacht? Ich meine im Allgemeinen, wie war die Stimmung während des Krieges? Es ist für uns sehr wichtig, dass Sie uns so eine Schätzung geben können. Andere frage ich nicht darüber, ich will bloß die Erlebnisse haben. Aber Sie sind Theologe, sie haben in einem Kloster gelebt, wie haben sie sich zu dem Krieg verhalten, zu den Nazis und allem?
Victor Ferdinansk: Diese Stimmung war sehr verschieden. Es kam darauf an, was für eine Person es gewesen ist. Die Älteren waren sozusagen verschworene Feinde des Nazismus.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Aber es gab auch jüngere Deutsche, die man...als, als Ausländer man wurde nicht ange...[unverständlich]. Wir sind im Kloster gelassen, aber die jungen Leute, Prediger sind eingerückt...
David Boder: Was heißt eingerückt?
Victor Ferdinansk: Eingerückt, das heißt in die Armee...
David Boder: Oh, sie wurden genommen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, genommen und sollten auch für die hitlerische Sache kämpfen.
David Boder: Hm.
Victor Ferdinansk: Die sind selbstverständlich durch die Hitler Schule durchgegangen und haben das Militär...haben den Militärdienst durch gemacht und, hm, als junge Leute waren die nicht genug kritisch, um die Sache richtig zu erkennen.
David Boder: Nun, wann haben Sie die gesehen? Nachdem sie das Militär durchgemacht haben oder wie war das Ganze?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, während der Kriegszeit sind sie doch oft und oft wieder mal auf Urlaub gekommen.
David Boder: Oh ja, nun?
Victor Ferdinansk: Und da konnte man sich im kurzen Gesprächen einen Blick bekommen, wie sie denken. Alle waren vom Hitler—man kann sagen—größtenteils begeistert.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Die jungen Leute.
Victor Ferdinansk: Aber ich habe allerdings auch getroffen, die die Hitler auch anders verstanden haben, als der Hitler selbst.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mal, wo...hm, wo war der Bischof Faulhaber? Wo war der jetzt, in München?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, zu dieser...war Bischof,...Kardinal Faulhaber...
David Boder: Kardinal Faulhaber?
Victor Ferdinansk: . . . war er in München.
Victor Ferdinansk: Ah, in München war er.
David Boder: Ja.
David Boder: Ja. Er war nicht pro Hitler.
Victor Ferdinansk: Nein, auf keinen Fall.
David Boder: Nun und die Anderen, sagen Sie mir, was haben sie gewusst von der Verfolgung von verschiedenen Völkern? Sagen wir, zum Beispiel, was haben Sie gewusst, was man mit den Juden getan hat, mit den Norwegern, mit den Zigeuners, und so weiter?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, was mit den Juden gemacht wurde, das wurde allen klar. Wir haben alle gewusst, dass die Juden eingesperrt werden und ermordet. Das haben auch die Deutschen gewusst. Aber dagegen war selbstverständlich nichts zu tun.
David Boder: Hm.
Victor Ferdinansk: Denn wir als Ausländer konnten es richtig schätzen, dass wir noch irgendwie als Menschen leben können und nicht eingesperrt sind.
David Boder: Hm, aber die Deutschen selbst, die deutschen Geistlichen, die haben es gewusst und was haben die darüber gesagt? Habt sie gesagt, dass es denen recht ist oder...?
Victor Ferdinansk: Die deutschen Geistlichen haben das nie gebilligt und bei den Vorlesungen bei dem Alten Testament, manchmal ist Frage aufgeworfen worden, was die Juden anbelangt. Da kann ich mich gut erinnern, dass der Herr Professor habe sich entschieden gegen die Misshandlung der Juden ausgesprochen.
David Boder: Und was haben die deutschen Studenten gesagt?
Victor Ferdinansk: Die deutschen Studenten, die haben auch immer die, hm, Herabsetzung einer bestimmten Nationalität auch abgelehnt—als Theologen - das haben sie immer gemacht.
David Boder: Nun, sagen Sie, wie haben sie sich zum Krieg verhalten? Wollten sie, dass Deutschland den Krieg gewinnen soll—und so weiter?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das war sehr verschieden, die...
David Boder: Sie verstehen, dass ich jetzt bloß...
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja.
David Boder: . . . eine solche Frage stelle,...
David Boder: . . . weil Sie ein besserer Beobachter sind als Andere.
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja.
David Boder: Sie waren ja nicht im Lager, Sie waren, hm, ein bisschen frei. Sie konnten mit den Deutschen reden, die Anderen konnten nicht, nicht wahr! Also weiter.
Victor Ferdinansk: Also es war sehr verschieden. Die Meisten wollten damit...der Krieg zu gewinnen, damit, hm, damit der Krieg gewonnen würde, denn damit habe sie gerade auch ihre Existenzmöglichkeiten gesehen.
David Boder: Oh ja, und sie waren doch...sie haben zum Lande gehört, nicht wahr?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja.
David Boder: Man kann das ja schließlich einem Menschen nicht übel nehmen, wenn er will, dass sein Land den Krieg gewinnt, sie verstehen das?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, ich verstehe Sie.
David Boder: Ja, nun sie wollten gewinnen. Wie kam es als es zum Ende kam? Nun? Waren Sie im Kloster, wie die Amerikaner herein kamen?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, ich war damals noch im Kloster.
David Boder: Und wie hat das ausgesehen, erzählen Sie mir.
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, die Meisten haben sich sehr ruhig verhalten und waren damit zufrieden, dass es endlich mit der Hitler Wirtschaft zu Ende geht.
David Boder: Und sie haben gewusst, die Amerikaner werden Ihnen nichts tun?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, selbstverständlich. Aber ich habe auch oft manche junge Soldaten getroffen, das heißt vorherige Soldaten, die sehr betrübt darüber waren, dass fremde Soldaten in ihr eigenes Land gekommen sind.
David Boder: Na ja, waren die nicht selber in anderen Ländern?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das stimmt schon, aber als Kinder ihrer Heimat, \waren sie darüber nicht besonders erfreut. Ich habe das wenigstens von dieser Seite beobachten können.
David Boder: Nun haben Sie gesehen unter den Deutschen oder unter den Geistlichen, dass die eine gewisse Kriegsschuld fühlten?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das habe ich nicht ganz genau feststellen können. Aber ich glaube, dass wenn man breiter denkt, dass jeder Mensch an der Sache seines Nächsten sich irgendwie schuldig fühlen kann...
David Boder: Hm.
Victor Ferdinansk: . . . und insoweit haben sie sich auch schuldig gefühlt.
David Boder: Nun ja, haben Sie gesehen, dass es irgendwie ein Gefühl war, dass man etwas gut machen muss, was man der Welt angetan hat?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das gerade habe ich nicht bemerkt, dass man das unbedingt gut machen kann.
David Boder: Gut machen muss!
Victor Ferdinansk: Oder muss, das habe ich nicht bemerkt.
David Boder: Nun sagen wir zum Beispiel, das. Sie waren jetzt in Amerika gewesen Kleider zu schicken für die Deutschen. Nicht wahr? Und so viel wird auch geschickt.
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja.
David Boder: Nun haben die Deutschen selber alles weggegeben, was sie weggeben konnten?
Victor Ferdinansk: Für wen? Für wen?
David Boder: Für die armen Deutschen und für die...für die anderen verschleppten Leute.
Victor Ferdinansk: Nein, denn die Deutschen haben die ganze Zeit die Verschleppten oder uns Ausländer wirklich misshandelt. Und dies als Theologe habe ich immer sehr tief gespürt und das ganze Übel fünf, sechs Jahre lang mit Schmerzen tragen müssen. Denn bei jedem Schritt, wo ich im Kloster war oder dort auf einer Behörde, wurde mir immer zu verstehen gegeben, dass ich ein Ausländer bin und nichts da zu suchen habe.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir zum Beispiel, warum gehen Sie jetzt auf die UNRRA Universität und gehen nicht direkt zu einer deutschen Universität Jura zu studieren?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ich kenne die Deutschen sehr gut und es würde mir wirklich weh tun, dass ich bei denen Zuflucht zu suchen gezwungen bin, wie ich hatte. Nur aus diesem Grunde will ich nichts mit die Deutschen zu tun haben.
David Boder: Aber Sie hatten...
Victor Ferdinansk: Die waren meine Feinde die ganze Zeit, weil ich die sehr gut kenne, ich habe die Gelegenheit gehabt dazu.
David Boder: Nun wo denken Sie denn Jura zu praktizieren?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, das ist eine Frage, auf die ich vorläufig keine Antwort geben kann. Ich wenigstens...ich hoffe wenigstens, dass die Zeit günstig sein wird und wir in ein paar Jahren wieder in unsere Heimat zurück kehren dürfen.
David Boder: Wie stellen Sie sich das vor? Denken Sie, dass die Russen weg gehen werden oder dass die Russen werden besser werden, oder was denken Sie?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, das ist meine persönlich Ansicht, dass die Lage, wie sie jetzt ist, nicht lange bestehen kann.
David Boder: In welchem Sinn?
Victor Ferdinansk: Das bedeutet alle...die ganze weltpolitische Lage.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Das ist ein Übergang von einem Stadium zum anderen Stadium.
Victor Ferdinansk: Und als solcher, das kann nicht lange bestehen bleiben. Das ist doch ein Weg, ein ewiges Fortschreiten. Und ich glaube, dass entweder auf einem friedlichen oder einem militärischen Wege wird uns die Möglichkeit verschafft in unsere Heimat zurück zu kehren.
David Boder: Haben Sie welche Verbindung mit Ihrer Heimat? Was hören Sie von ihren...sie haben dort, sie haben doch Eltern gehabt, nicht wahr?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja, ich habe meine Eltern in meiner Heimat, ja.
David Boder: Wann haben Sie zuletzt von denen gehört?
Victor Ferdinansk: Die Verbindung mit meinen Eltern ist abgebrochen in dem Jahre 1944, als die Russen an der litauischen Grenze, an der westlichen Grenze standen...und jeder Postverkehr zwischen Deutschland und Litauen abgebrochen wurde.
David Boder: Hm.
Victor Ferdinansk: Seit dem habe ich von meinen Eltern gar nichts gehört und ich befürchte sehr, dass sie nicht mehr am Leben sind.
David Boder: Gibt es nicht irgend welchen Weg sich zu verständigen durch das Rote Kreuz oder irgendwie?
Victor Ferdinansk: Wenn es auch geben würde, würde ich das nicht probieren.
David Boder: Ja?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ich habe Angst meinen Eltern zu sagen, dass ich lebendig bin und mich in Deutschland befinde. Denn darin würden die Russen oder die Kommunisten deutlich in meinen Eltern ein Element sehen, das Ihnen unlieb ist.
David Boder: Nun sagen Sie mir, wie geht es hier an der Universität?
Victor Ferdinansk: Ja von dieser Universität bin ich sehr begeistert und mit meinem ganzen Herzen bin ich dabei. Aber jeder Anfang ist auch schwer, darum ist der Anfang an dieser Universität auch sehr schwer. Wir haben auch sehr wenig Geld, auch wenige Präparate, auch keine Laboratorien...
David Boder: Wie steht es mit den Büchern?
Victor Ferdinansk: Auch fast keine Bibliothek.
David Boder: Sie sind ein Student, sie studieren Jura. Studieren Sie das deutsche Gesetz oder was für ein Gesetz studieren Sie?
Victor Ferdinansk: Als Juristen und als Studenten in dem dritten und zweiten Semester studieren wir gewöhnlich die Einführungen in das Recht, das heißt das römische Recht.
David Boder: Ja.
Victor Ferdinansk: Einführung in das Recht, Soziologie, allgemeine Volkswirtschaftslehre, Statistik und das sind so allgemeine Fächer, die für alle Nationalitäten und Nationen gemeinsam sind.
David Boder: Nun, es tut mir leid, wie müssen abbrechen. Ich möchte wirklich sehr gerne jeden von Euch für eine Stunde haben oder zwei—vielleicht wäre das besser. Aber Sie sehen, ich würde vorziehen zwei Personen oder drei Personen für drei Stunden zu haben, statt jeden für eine halbe Stunden, nicht wahr. Aber da es doch so verschiedene Gruppen hier gibt, will ich keinem wehe tun, nicht wahr. Und ich vielleicht werde ich mir von der ganzen Geschichte mir etwas kollektiv zusammen stellen, nicht wahr. Mein Name wird hier mit ihrem Direktor bleiben, wenn Sie mir mal schreiben wollen. Ich weiß nicht, ob ich viel tun kann, aber ich werde es wenigstens zu wem hin schicken, der etwas tun könnte. Es hat mir wirklich gefreut Sie kennen zu lernen. Danke sehr.
Victor Ferdinansk: Ich danke Ihnen auch.